c'est un couac dont la préfecture de
seine-et-marne se serait certainement
bien passé
après avoir annoncé mardi après midi sur
son site internet la fin de l'obligation
du port du masque à l'extérieur sur tout
le département à compter de ce mercredi
la préfecture a opéré un virage à 180
degrés en début de soirée le port du
masque est maintenue en seine et marne
en seine et marne le masque en extérieur
est obligatoire jusqu'au 31 mai 2021 au
moins un revirement qui laisse les
internautes dans l'incompréhension
on se moque de nous clairement ordres et
contre ordres depuis des mois demain
fera t-il marcher sur les mains en
extérieur en tout cas en marche sur la
tête
ça va être compliqué de faire appliquer
le port du masque les règles changent
sans cesse il y a deux heures le port
était devenu facultatif
selon le parisien la préfecture de seine
et marne reconnaîtrait une erreur de
manipulation et une décision un peu trop
rapide
une erreur également commise par la
préfecture de la creuse
interrogé lundi sur une possible levée
du port du masque en extérieur le
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
avait bien fait part de sa confiance à
ce sujet mais avait aussi nuancé ses
propos
je ne crois pas qu'on soit amené à
demander aux français de porter un
masque lorsqu'ils seront sur la plage ou
sur un transat cet été ce n'est pas
encore la situation à l'heure où je vous
parle le port du masque est obligatoire
y compris en extérieur mais si la
circulation du virus continue à baisser
ça va être rapidement envisagée
bien qu'un peu perdue face à la
situation les seine et marne et honteuse
aussi leur avis sur l'utilité du port du
masque en extérieur non je pense pas que
ce soit utile de du fait que
on soit l'air libre donc pour moi c'est
pas un problème les gens sont assez
espacés comme vous pouvez le voir ici
donc
donc pour moi c'est pas un problème
peut-être que potentiellement le dans
des magasins on peut le garder parce que
les gestes barrières sont plus
restreints mais à l'extérieur non si
chacun y met du sien je pense que
l'utilité du masque n'est pas nécessaire
en seine et marne département
essentiellement rural et le plus grandes
villes de france
le port du masque en extérieur ne semble
donc pas toujours adaptés le taux
d'incidence il était vendredi dernier
descendu à 218 cas de kobe de 19 pour
cent mille habitants soit une baisse de
24% en sept jours